[Musique]
oh merde
je suis raiden dieu de la foudre ok je
vois ça veut dire qu'il ya une nouvelle
vidéo qui vient de commencer
à bon dieu vous êtes wright est le dieu
de la foudre mais c'est incroyable oui
où est-ce qu'ils ne votent porto non pas
celui de la foudre là je suis en avant
dior c'est ça bougeait pas je vais
chercher mon costume
[Musique]
tue a été sélectionné parmi les plus
grands guerriers pour participer au
grand tournoi qui rétablira l'équilibré
dans ce monde le monde
le quoi
le mot
le mortal quoi tu le fais exprès là oui
un petit peu
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le mortal kombat a lieu tous les ans
chaque année des champions de la terre
et de l'autre monde s'affrontent dans un
tournoi aux proportions épiques
cela fait neuf ans
tué le dernier espoir si nous perdons
encore cette année l'équilibré ne sera
jamais rétabli qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire par équilibre regarde
la folie des hommes
[Musique]
bon sang c'est scorpions encore attendre
chang song lui aussi participons mortal
kombat
qu'est ce que je suis censé faire moi je
sais pas me battre au taquet jugèrent
[Musique]
je suis prêt à affronter le champ
oh mon dieu le tournoi donc commencer la
première étape pour arriver à la grande
finale sera ce jeu dirigeons nous vers
le lieu de l'épreuve
[Musique]
et
si les scorpions c'est
par rapport aux signes
c'est parce que ça pique
le cinquième élément un défi le français
les plus connus à l'étranger qu'on aime
ou qu'on aime pas le film graphiquement
il faut quand même lui reconnaître une
certaine classe pour cette époque après
bon le scénario pour rappel on y voit
korben un chauffeur de taxi qui se
retrouve embarqué malgré lui dans une
quête épique avec lille où l'incarnation
de l'élément de l'amour
afin de combattre le terrible sort et
sauver la terre d'une planète tueuse
lancé par le grand ennemi nommé le mal
[Applaudissements]
à ce que le mal c'est pas bien et que
l'amour c'est plus fort que le mal ouais
c'est sûr que ça veut dire mieux quand
j'avais 14 ans mais tout ça dans le jeu
et on sent rôle korben doit s'infiltrer
dans le nucléaire lève pour retrouver le
laboratoire de construction cellulaire
là il doit relancer le processus de
matérialisation de lille ou halem de la
carte génétique
c'est un chauffeur de taxi
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote est le
cinquième élément pour nous c'est devenu
une blague parce que ce je traîne dans
nos cartons depuis environ 2011 et à
chaque fois on repousse ce test parce
que c'est une [ __ ] c'est nul le
premier de vous deux terminé ce jeu aura
accès à la grande finale que le tournoi
comment
ok bon ben si c'est pour sauver la terre
alors le jeu est donc le tps on va
incarner successivement korben et lilou
lilou qui a pas de nom d'ailleurs un
dans ce jeu autant encore ben ça va
mais lille où on a juste le bruit d'un
gars qui éjacule dans son pantalon
la principale différence entre les deux
personnages et que corbeil peut utiliser
des flingues et lilou est plus souple et
peu utilisé une forme de magie et par
plus souple je veux juste dire qu'elle
peut se mettre à quatre pattes
et non je ne ferai pas de blague le
dessus ce qui donne certains passages
complètement débiles dans le jeu ou quoi
mais là où lille ou peut passer
c'est vrai que clairement là on a besoin
de la tête si seulement j'avais des
pouvoirs magiques un joli petit cul
l'âge pourrait passer évidemment dans ce
genre de test la comparaison avec tomb
raider qui est sorti deux ans avant
d'être évidente vu que c'est à peu près
le même type de gameplay si on excepte
les sauts mais paradoxalement la chose
la plus ratée du jeu c'est aussi pour
moi celle qui est le plus difficile à
vous montrer c'est la maniabilité le
premier truc qui te saute aux yeux quand
tu le mot je sais que korben va vite
dans les lignes droites mais par contre
dès que tu lui demande de se tourner
c'est pas là c'est pas comme s'ils se
tourner était un truc qu'on utilise est
absolument tout le japon redonne alors
déjà faire des combats entracte au plc
nul sur cet accident fait autant pas de
faire chanter et en plus forcément comme
menée sur playstation il fallait bien
que les me baigne dans cette espèce de
sous pas la merde où tu vois pas à 20
mètres devant toi ansa
vapeur meilleures anecdotes ce
brouillard de guerre qu'on voit souvent
dans les vieux jeux comme ça ça porte un
nom technique ça s'appelle j'ai pas eu
le temps d'optimiser le moteur de mon
jeu alors je met un pansement qui sont
le vieux qu pour pas que ça tourne à 3
fps et sortir le jeu quand même et
maintenant qu'est ce qu'il manque et ben
oui vous le savez elle est là elle est
là surtout les jeux playstation qui
sentent le vieux chien mouillé elle
revient chaque fois on s'en lasse jamais
cherché à le tout n'importe quoi
chaque année
le tour de paule est nominé papara alors
je dis pas tomb raider avait aussi le
même genre de problème avec le ciblage
des ennemis mais les développeurs
avaient résolu ça justement faisant
encore que lara évolue toujours dans des
décors très large mais il a forcément
comme c'est des couloirs on a le grand
classique des jeux playstation avec la
caméra qui est prise de convulsions
toutes les deux minutes qui se met à
filmer vos doigts de pied super la le
cadrage j'adore [ __ ] c'est pas
compliqué dans un couloir tu mets la
caméra derrière et si le joueur se
retourne tout bascule de l'autre côté et
tu fais pas ça d'ailleurs ce jeu reprend
énormément d'éléments de tomb raider
mais s'il vous plaît il ya un truc que
je vous demande de ne pas reprendre ne
fait pas de ce jeu à l'abir je te
l'avais [ __ ] évidemment comme c'est le
feu n'était pas assez constipé le
cinquième élément a essayé de reprendre
ce truc de tomb raider avec des
interrupteurs active et qui ouvre des
portes à l'autre bout du niveau sauf que
dont on devrait y dort la caméra bouge
jusqu'à la porte qui vient de s'ouvrir
du coup tu vois le chemin effectué ou
alors c'est genre tu passe d'abord
devant une porte et ensuite tu croises
l'interrupteur de la porte en question
comme ça tu sais où elle apporte sa
porte un nom ça mais chérie ça s'appelle
du level design
dans ce [ __ ] de jeu c'est genre tu
croises l'interrupteur tulle active
ça te montre une scène cinématique de
portes qui s'ouvrent et alors je crois
que tu montre sage membrolle [ __ ] je
sais pas où elle est a portes de merde
là je suis jamais passé devant et tous
les murs ressemble aussi sa porte aux
normes chérie ça s'appelle de la merde
il est donc temps de passer au deuxième
personnage ce coup ci vous allez
contrôler lille ou en ville ou étant
l'incarnation de l'élément de l'amour
lilou ne peut donc pas se battre avec
des armées est obligé de se battre au
corps à corps l'utilisation des grenades
explosives est autorisée tant que je
suis sûr fait avec
et le souci c'est que lille ou galère
lille ou galère façon ceinture blanche
de judo et là où le jeu est pitoyable
avec aux rebelles mais au moins votre
arme elle réussit à toucher des trucs au
corps à corps c'est terminé vous ne
touchez à rien
[Musique]
le système de combat entier de l'île où
se fait avec un gameplay qui est cassé
ou vous touchez une fois sur trois
c'est ce qui manque aux jeux vidéo en
france c'est un genre de gordon ramsay
ou de philippe etchebest je suis testeur
de jeux vidéo depuis plus de dix ans et
j'en ai vu passer les merdes et
aujourd'hui une fois de plus je vais
devoir aller dans un studio de
développement je suis là pour redresser
la barre même si je dois être leur pire
cauchemar
qu'est ce que j'ai dit sur les niveaux
dans les égouts tient dit quoi qu'est-ce
qui est ratée dans ton jeu et combats au
corps à corps et comment elle se bat
lille ou dans ton jeu
évidemment comme personne n'a pensé à
lui mais le jeu avant que le chine dans
les kiosques qui se sont dit aussi
qu'ils allaient mettre deux fois plus
d'ennemis pour encore plus de fun et
c'est quoi ces ennemis d'ailleurs non
parce que si nous verrons dans la
technologie pour faire voler des robots
ont fait pas ça notre nouvelle
génération de robots policiers sera
notre arme décisive pour éradiquer le
crime
[Musique]
allez je vais dire en compliments sur
cette partie quand lee lou marsh elle
roule du cube voit la marche pas level
design est complètement foiré le jeu est
moche comme une verrue et les combats
sont affreux mais au look you pas
donc voila et en plus comme le scénar
n'a rien à voir avec le film on n'a même
pas le plaisir de revoir les mêmes
scènes que dans le film à la place on a
évidemment tous les clichés possibles
des développeurs en manque d'imagination
comme ces fameux niveau nommé usines
mais vous savez ces usines classiques
qu'on voit dans les jeux vidéos avec des
machineries énorme des rivières de l'avs
et c'est enfin seule usine vsb
l'objectif des différents niveaux sera
donc de retrouver en premier les
activateurs des différentes pierres des
éléments ouais donc les activateurs ça
veut dire genre du feu pour la pierre du
feu de l'eau pour un tiers de l'eau etc
donc on va se taper des niveaux avec
autant de fun qu'une soirée à écouter
les anecdotes de voisinage de chez mamie
est aussi beau que si quelqu'un avait
chez sur mes lunettes tout ça pour
trouver l'activateur de l'air un élément
essentiel à notre quête
ventilateur
vous avez de l'asthme non parce que même
si c'était le cas vous savez ce qui
aurait marché aussi c'est de faire ça
évidemment c'est pareil pour tous les
autres pour l'élément belot pas question
d'aller acheter une bouteille de volvic
chez l'épicier arabe du coin de banon
serait trop simple au lieu de ça on
préfère faire un long niveau dans un
aéroport avec des tapis roulants vous
savez les fameux tapis roulant avec les
presses dans les aéroports qui servait
écrasé les valises vous savez sur un
marché aussi pour les mangues l'eau
et il faut que la récupérer tous les
activateurs des éléments maintenant il
faut récupérer les pierres des éléments
ben oui on va allonger la sauce du coût
des niveaux entiers avec des passages en
plate forme avec toujours cette caméra
qui filme tout sauf la plate forme je
dire à quoi sert cet angle de caméra je
vois pas sur quoi j'ai cote mais
pourquoi vous me faites subir ça bordel
fait comme dans votre [ __ ] de fils de
mr d'enfoncer les quatre éléments dans
le cul de la chanteuse et lâchez moi les
couilles et ses terribles en plus parce
que les niveaux de ce jeu sont justes
reliés entre eux par un texte pourri un
pauvre extraits du film du coup j'ai
même pas besoin de finir le jeu pour
savoir qu'à la fin ma seule récompense
sera un extrait du film sauf que quand
tu joues au cinquième élément le je sais
que tu as déjà vu le film
alors pourquoi je m'emmerde bonjour
c'est l'avocat du diable c'était pour
souligner que les cinématiques de ce
jour on était remonté dans un ordre
différent pour offrir un genre
d'histoire alternative
ce qui au final offre une expérience
inédite aux joueurs
voilà je vais y aller
ouais vous savez quoi je suis trop vieux
pour ces conneries j'ai pas envie de me
taper 2 juin entier alors on n'a qu'à
dire qu'il a gagné tant pis pour
l'équilibré
vraiment je penserai par les fusils
félicitations champions tu as gagné le
droit d'accéder à la grande finale
comment ça j'ai dit que j'avais
abandonné c'est lui qui a gagné
à
nous allons désormais nous diriger vers
le lieu de la grande finale dans l'autre
monde
par contre si tu me permets je récupère
ça
[Musique]
bienvenue champion de la terre bienvenue
au total combat sanguy
comment as-tu l'an dernier havas
tranquille ça roule
annoncé quatre d'entre eux
écoutent
le champion de la terre est venu nous
défier qui se dressera face à lui et
remportera la finale
[Musique]
je vous demande revenant de faire un
tonnerre d'applaudissements pour le
champion de l'autre monde le bim sa il
n'entend pas le droit au show possible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout cela nous promet un match difficile
cherchant on est tout à fait en séries
dont il faudra beaucoup de courage aux
champions de la terre pour pouvoir
réussir à revenir après neuf défaites
consécutives
et rappelons que le vainqueur pourra
rétablir l'équilibré et repartira avec
un merveilleux conte bits et les
cassettes ainsi qu'un abonnement de deux
ans à notre partenaire télé z il sans
plus attendre mon chéri hayden on peut
constater que les candidats s'installe
devant leurs machines la tension est
palpable
je sens que la rencontre va être
mémorable c'est trop de pression moi je
suis passé en arriver un courage
champions de la terre tu peux le faire
j'ai pas le c'est pas grave subzero gars
de ton sang froid reste cool
cool comme
si je réussis pas à rétablir l'équilibré
ce qui va se passer tous ces golfeurs
ses joueurs de billard calme toi tout va
bien se passer imagine que tu es chez
toi ok
j'imagine que je suis chez moi j'imagine
que je suis chez moi j'imagine que je
suis chez moi j'imagine à bakool ça
marche bien c'est vachement pratique en
plus bref quand on parle de jeux de
combat on pense tout de suite à deux
grands noms du jeu vidéo street fighter
et de goreux love moi j'veux bien luné
chaud bref street fighter et mortal
kombat et pourquoi tu parlais pas des
bras gueule
on a déjà abordé brièvement cette
licence à travers les films dans
certains hors sujet et le jeu mortal
kombat spécial forces il ya longtemps
sorti en 92 m mortal kombat voulait être
le concurrent direct de street fighter
mais en apportant le réalisme de
personnages digitaliser et surtout une
bonne grosse dose de violence qui soyons
honnêtes était le seul intérêt de jouer
un mortel combat on va pas me faire
croire qu on y jouer pour son gameplay
bref je vous apprends rien si je vous
dis que les jeux mortal kombat sont
quasi tous intégralement des jeux de
baston mais en 97 me do et décident de
commander un jeu qui sera ce coup-ci
centré sur le personnage de sub zero
devenu un peu malgré lui un des
personnages préférés des fans lors
c'était censé être un méchant à la base
mortal kombat mythologie sub zero
efforts donc sur nintendo 64 ou
playstation est ce que si terminer le
jeu de baston on aura un beat them up
jouable en solo nous savons pour faire
un dieu nc on était vachement plus
pratique de prendre un jeu de baston un
genre je suis pas pourtant le combat
[Musique]
jeu de combat mortal kombat arrête le
jeu commence donc par une définition du
mot bitolo j ouer et je dis bien une
définition c'est pas genre une citation
de platon pour faire un peu classe non
ac c'est la définition du petit robert
c'est-à-dire nom masculin singulier
défini bla bla bla déjà tu vois direct
comment les leaders ils considèrent les
gens qui achètent un jeu mortal kombat
que boyle et où le sang au niveau de
l'histoire le jeu est une préquelle à
mortal kombat ou sub zero est engagé par
un type nommé quan chi pour voler le
parchemin des éléments
hockey bref le jeu est donc beat them up
en pur fausse 3d puisqu'il n'y a aucune
notion de profondeur les graphismes qui
sont d'ailleurs également les mêmes que
pour les jeux de baston c'est à dire des
personnages digitalisées
au niveau des contrôles c'est exactement
les mêmes que dans mortal kombat en jeu
de baston et l'a déjà c'est un premier
problème parce que les contrats mer bon
et bien puisque le jeu insiste on va
commencer là dessus les id box de ce jeu
sont cramés les pilotes ne touchent à
des kilomètres [ __ ] mais comment ça me
touche pour regarder je pourrais tracer
une vie du même pas ça me laisse le
coude quel [ __ ] riz et ce jeu d'arad
pas une on a aussi le grand classique de
l'écran qui codent le mauvais côté ça ne
sert à rien cet espace libre regarder je
pourrais construire un appart c'est bon
je reste calme je suis subzero je suis
un ninja ninja c'est chinois sub zero
suis un ninja de chine franchement je
fais un aparté mais sub zero est
vraiment un ninja de chine ce qui est
stupide parce que les ninjas ces
japonais il y avait une chanson
officielle qui s'appelle super au
chinese ninja warrior est clairement là
il y avait dû lever lé niveau culture
oui j'ai composé une chanson sur l'asie
parce que j'adore ce pays
elle chine ont ducati quand les moines
shaolin
jean-françois françois ne ratez pas ces
nouveaux titres comme quand on est un
hymne dia et c'est beaucoup trop violent
un album déjà annulé bonjour c'est
encore l'avocat du diable c'était pour
souligner que seul 0 il n'est pas
vraiment un ninja il appartient en
réalité à un clan chinoise
très bien c'est une bonne journée aller
reprenons on va essayer de passer en
marchant
c'est bien bien on va essayer d'y aller
au courant
harper ce jeu de ces morts et pourquoi
cet abruti recul à chaque fois qu'ils te
fait toucher
je le hais je le hais avec son costume
pourri et sa gueule de con là j'étais
plus agile quand je peux aider en 50 kg
hana l'écoutent pas tes traits mots en
fait c'est toute la logique du jeu qui
est foirée je veux dire par exemple à la
moitié du niveau vous arrivez à une
fenêtre quand vous sautez
vous mourrez quand tu sautes par une
fenêtre et que tu meurs comme une merde
logiquement en tant que joueur tu te dis
c'est pas par là donc la nature par un
arrière en te disant qu'il ya un autre
chemin mais non la solution était bien
ici c'est juste qu'il faut d'abord sauté
sur la petite rambarde attendre d'avoir
cette petite animation et ensuite sauté
en étant collés aux purs pour rebondir
sur rohan et atterrir en bas vous
connaissez le principe des sauts de
l'ange dans les jeux c'est quand vous
devez sauter sur un truc qui est hors de
vue mais même ce saut va à l'encontre de
cette règle raté puisque normalement
saut de l'ange s'est tu dois sauter le
plus loin possible et y sinon ça ils ont
réussi à rater un truc raté du coup raté
un truc raté ça s'annule bref le premier
livre se termine avec le célèbre duel
entre scorpion et sub zero leur tout
premier duel celui où sub zero dessus à
scorpion pour la première fois et
deviendra son grand ennemi aller le jeu
c'est le moment c'est au moment c'est ça
que tu sais faire c'est pour ça que les
gens achètent alors montreuil ou de la
violence contre nous du sort
pour battre tout ce petit monde vous
aurez donc les même coup que le jeu
classique ainsi que quelques attaques
spéciales que vous allez débloquer au
fur et à mesure que vous tuer des
ennemis l'attak de glace de sub zero par
exemple ces quarts de cercle croit
facile ou votre deuxième coup spécial
c'est la glissade qui marchent pas c'est
croit plus seront plus heureux plus
arrière as il est d'ailleurs chaque
niveau sera entrecoupé de petites scènes
filmées avec des gens en costume qui
d'ailleurs sont filmés dans un tout
petit studio on est vraiment tout ceci
parce que je veux bien qu'ils aient pas
beaucoup de place pour se parler mais
personne au monde ne se parlent d'aussi
près oui bonjour je voudrais une
baguette ou eric et cuisson bref niveau
histoire du jeu après avoir récupéré le
parchemin des éléments votre boss vous
envoie ensuite récupérer les quatre
partis d'une amulette dans le temple de
l'eau du feu du vent et de la terre
waouh ça c'est original
shire évidemment tous les niveaux
suivants sont à s'arracher les yeux de
la tête je veux dire il tombe des phases
de plateforme avec des trucs en 3d jeu
je suis en 2d on n'est même pas sur le
même plan d'existence et avec cette
différence de graphisme ce soit
peut-être pas senti jouer mais c'est
extrêmement dur pour juger si le truc
sur lequel tu peux sauter et en face de
toi ou non et
et chaque fois que tu meurs tu as droit
à cette scène cinématique au bout avec
le gars qui
essaient c'est quoi ce niveau d'ailleurs
c'était censé être un [ __ ] de temple
shaolin à la base je rappelle
affectivement et aucun coup travaux à
faire là bas et on arriva enfin cette
partie du test où je peux vous parler de
l'intelligence artificielle des ennemis
c'est de la merde on va successivement
alterner entre les ennemis de base qui
ont tous été programmés en jeu tant des
claviers sur les murs attention je skie
à nos deux subzero je bloque et jeu
contre attaque et je cros
et des boss qui vont varier des fois ils
vont avoir leur instinct et des fois ils
auront l'intelligence de tabouret
[Musique]
oui
stupidité
après pour le reste on peut installer
plus clair de votre temps à vous étaient
essentiellement des claude debard a calé
ce d'exception arriveront bien plus tard
largement après la moitié du jeu hein
quoi affronter des personnages de mortal
kombat offert tenez vous voulez pas
plutôt des robots géants un des
dinosaures en 3d qui crachent du feu ah
oui et on enlever le sang aussi ah oui
et on connaît aussi vous pouvez niquez
vos mères bon après niveau placement on
va dire que les ennemis placés aux piles
qui se suicident c1 reste un petit peu
rigolo mais ça devient moins drôle comme
ça te bloque complètement dans ta
progression et [ __ ] [ __ ] mais jamais
berne attend je le fais je le fais oui
blanc mais quel enfer ce niveau et le
pire c'est que c'est pas le seul endroit
dans le niveau comme ça les ennemis sont
attirés par la présence du coup ils sont
tout le temps très collé les bords
[ __ ] de quimper de mer ou là là là là
je crois que le champion de la terre pue
la merde mon cher chongqing tout à fait
mouche à rieden d'ailleurs on voit leurs
lentilles tout de suite à une légère
perte de sang froid de la part du joueur
terriens ailleurs on en profite pour
saluer le magnifique travail du staff
médical pour voir actuellement à l'écran
et profitons de cette petite pause pour
marquer une page de publicité
retour dans les studios attend quoi déjà
ah bah oui les gens en tout sept blocs
d'accord et après on dit que c'est moi
le seigneur du mal très bien en fait
c'est pas trop tôt ah on me fait signe
qu'il ya du nouveau la situation s'est
débloquée côté terrien oddo match alors
je vais pas faire tout le jeu
essentiellement parce que le passage
dans les égouts pardon le temple de
l'eau est particulièrement insupportable
le niveau prend plusieurs heures à lui
tout seul à se finir et c'est d'une
lenteur abominable c'est un enchaînement
de labyrinthe de phases de plate forme
molle de marquez koala et marquer ou
démarquer mortal kombat il est où le
combat ta mère le seul truc est mortelle
dans ton jeu c'est l'ennui matt et moi
les phases qu'on se tape dans ce jeu des
fois
[ __ ]
mais c'est pas vrai
mais c'est à devenir fou un simple
impérial et berlin temporisent actions
dans une partie d'europa universalis
ouais mortal kombat mythologie a été un
[ __ ] déchets qu'absolument quand même
en ça devait être le premier jeu d'une
série sur les origines story de chaque
personnage mais finalement sub zero sera
le seul et après ça on n'en parlera plus
jamais les
[Musique]
coups durs pour la terre 10e défaite
consécutive je crois que le retour de l'
équilibre ce sera pas pour demain et
mordelles ses trucs et votre truc là
c'est son jeu cette fois c'en est le
principal du jeu qui joue dedans peu de
mots fusent
si on en croit des
champions le vainqueur du mortal kombat
n'est déclaré vainqueur que s'il soulève
le trophée tout n'est pas perdu
réfléchis utilise ta tête quelle est ma
tête
utiliser ma tête oui bien sûr
[Musique]
victory
mais qu'est ce que vous avez fait une
ambulance peuple allemand
ces kits malade que tu as ramené non moi
je vous invite à une compet de jeux
vidéo il ya une bonne ambiance et le
tout mais [ __ ] mec mais du coup ça
veut dire que j'ai gagné ou alors
techniquement oui mais on va peut-être
pas tarder à y aller on ses pupilles
sont dilatées
donc on est en train de le perdre j'm'en
fous et vous avez vous expliquer chez
les flics hassoun a rien à fêter nous
vous croyons pas de talent et
au mental thomas
[Musique]
oh
en
[Musique]